pense pas que le marché que la
consommation est ralentie pendant cette
période
au contraire merci beaucoup frédéric
ploquin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes l'auteur de ce
livre est mon livre passionnant les
marques aux français brise l'omerta
c'est aux éditions albin michel merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis sachez que
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast sur le site rtl france point tv
à bientôt
[Musique]
oui
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
un samedi de mobilisation en france
contre le racisme et les violences
policières selon le mot d'ordre de
manifestation à paris mais aussi à
marseille lille toulouse ou encore à
rennes
les protestataires réclament notamment
la suspension immédiate des agents mis
en cause pour violences et homicides
ainsi que la suppression des
propositions de loi sécurité globale et
séparatisme des rassemblements maintenu
malgré des nouvelles mesures de
confinement dans seize départements
l'union européenne menace de bloquer les
exportations du vaccin astrazeneca si
elle ne reçoit pas d'abord ses
livraisons la présidente de la
commission européenne met en garde le
groupe suédo britannique qui a annoncé
de nouveaux retards astrazeneca mise en
difficulté ces derniers jours après une
suspicion d'effets secondaires graves
la vaccination a repris hier dans
plusieurs europe et dans plusieurs pays
européens où certains dirigeants
n'hésitent pas à se mettre en scène pour
redonner confiance dans son cerveau
[Musique]
les manifestants prêts à se battre
jusqu'au bout contre la junte militaire
en birmanie
nouvelle manifestation ce samedi malgré
la répression depuis le coup d'état du
1er février elle a fait près de 240
morts chez les civils
des centaines de personnes sont
également portées disparues
une situation qui entraîne un exode
massif des habitants de rangoon la
capitale économique
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france est à pas
l'impunité clan des slogans scandés par
les manifestants qui ont défilé dans
plusieurs villes de france à l'appel de
collectifs dont le réseau dont traite
vérité justice
la marche de solidarité la coordination
stop loi sécurité globale ils protestent
contre le racisme et les violences
policières et réclame la suspension
immédiate des agents mis en cause pour
violences ou pour homicide
ainsi que la suppression des
propositions de lois séparatisme et
sécurité globale la proposition de loi
sécurité globale qui a été adopté jeudi
en première lecture au sénat à paris
trois mille cinq cents personnes se sont
réunies selon la préfecture le cortège a
rejoint la place de la bastille en fin
de journée une manifestation qui a suivi
notre reporter thomas bonnin plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont défilé dans
les rues de la capitale ce samedi pour
dénoncer les violences policières et le
racisme
une manifestation à l'appel de plusieurs
organisations syndicales politiques et
associatives mais également des familles
de personnes qui ont été tuées après ce
qui est présenté comme des violences
policières vous propose d'écouter
quelques témoignages que nous avons
recueillis dans cette manifestation
le droit d'expression c'est un droit
fondamental savez il est inscrit dans la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme donc c'est la démocratie la
démocratie repose sur sur la liberté
d'expression donc tout ce qui met en
cause cette liberté d'expression mais
faut qu'on se batte
il faut qu'on soit là pour pour
conserver ses liberté d'expression la
liberté de manifestation le manier la
possibilité de manifestations grave
sans violence bien sûr un pacifique mais
pour nous c'est des combats essentiels
aujourd'hui le fait de ne pas pouvoir
filmer ça va donner encore plus de
possibilités aux policiers de sévir
aujourd'hui si tout le monde connaît
georges floyd c'est parce qu'il a eu les
vidéos
sinon aujourd'hui on nous aurait dit
georges floyd est mort d'une crise
cardiaque
aujourd'hui c'est tout le monde
connaissait drechou vient c'est parce
qu'il a usé ses vidéos avant que les
vidéos elles ne sortent on nous avait
dit cédric je viens mémoire d'une crise
cardiaque
aujourd'hui tout le monde connaît michel
est claire s'il n'y avait pas eu ces
vidéos michel est clair en prison
je vous rappellerai que ces policiers
qui ont tabassé michel éclair de son
domicile
en vingt ans de métier combien de fois
on dit c'est bien dans cette procédure
dans ses écrits on a un abus qu on a pu
constater qu'ils ont fait défaut et qui
combien de fois ont-ils fait défaut
écrit voilà pourquoi est-ce que vous
devons film et c'est un devoir pour
pouvoir montrer la vérité un cortège qui
a été rejoint par les gilet jaune qui
ont également fait le déplacement après
avoir organisé leur propre manifestation
en fin de matinée ils ont grossi les
rangs de cette manifestation pour
dénoncer eux aussi les dérives de la
police notamment lors du maintien de
l'ordre et lors de toutes les
manifestations qui se sont déroulées ces
derniers mois je propose d'écouter
jérôme rodrigues au vu des perspectives
aujourd'hui par rapport au confinement
aux lois liberticides qui ont imposé
on s'est compliqué
sur groupe est assez facilement je pense
qu'il serait important aujourd'hui de
répondre à l'appel du 1er mai en appel
qui existe depuis de longues années de
le voir se regrouper avec l'ensemble des
citoyens en colère ce jour-là que tous
les groupes d'action qu'ils soient
syndicales politiques associatifs de
pouvoir descendre que ce problème et et
montrer notre force et notre
mécontentement à l'ensemble du
gouvernement
on se reprend l'ensemble des français et
pourquoi pas rejoindre le plus beau
point de france celui des champs elysées
en la visant à travaille pour ça une
manifestation qui s'est déroulée dans le
calme aucune tension il faut dire que le
dispositif de sécurité qui avaient été
déployés étaient particulièrement
impressionnant avec de nombreux crs
gendarmes mobiles ou encore des membres
de la brave la brigade de répression de
l'action violente qui avait été déployé
spécialement pour cette manifestation
aujourd'hui et réactions à présent de
nos invités aujourd'hui sur notre
antenne et côté si les policiers ne
peuvent peut être filmé lors des
manifestations lorsqu'ils commettent des
entre kim et pas vu des violences
policières
eh bien ça ne pourrait plus en apporter
la preuve
voyez donc là il ya un double départ à
côté on nous parle de sécurité donc des
forces de police lors des interventions
de manifestations et de l'autre de
l'autre côté on nous dit ben écoute et
oui le coeur du problème c'est de
pouvoir voir les les agents de police
lorsqu'ils quand même des infractions
il faut bien comprendre que ou nasri
prend leur enfant je voulais que dans
certains pays notamment des pays anglo
saxons cette question a déjà purgé un
intervenant toutes les 10 secondes en
france ça correspond à peu près à trois
millions et demi d'intervention par an
et si on veut remettre l'institution
policière avec des cas qui sont avérés
c'est une enquête qui peut déterminer
s'il ya violence ou non et bien là
si on veut remettre en question notre
institution c'est sûr qu'on peut prendre
des cas isolés mais de notre côté on va
pas remettre par exemple l'enseignement
en france si on si on reprend deux ou
trois cadres de pédophilie donc il faut
il faut il faut rester d'être froide il
faut pas remettre en question le travail
des policiers au quotidien qui sont
victimes de violences comme je voulais
dit comme malheureusement comme vous
journalistes vous avez subi des
violences au sein de certains
rassemblements interdits
c'est une dérive encore plus autoritaire
qui va comme environ
on voit bien qui a bien tout un panel de
mesures qui sont mises en oeuvre pour
réduire encore la liberté d'expression
et dallas tout ça est fait contre les
manifestants s'est pas fait voyez si on
disait par exemple on va développer la
police dans les quartiers difficiles
pour essayer de réduire les délits qui
est le quotidien que qui des fois j'ai
qui des fois même qui souvent viennent
de la population pourrait dire bon
pourquoi pas mais là toutes les mesures
et puissant prises visent à limiter les
manifestations d'opposition à la
politique gouvernementale
c'est cette loi là où il faut supprimer
des manifestations maintenu malgré les
nouvelles restrictions qui touchent 16
départements dont l'île de france elles
sont entrées en vigueur à minuit premier
jour ce samedi donc de se re confinement
bien que le terme à ce débat du côté de
l'exécutif qui préfère lui évoqué des
mesures pour freiner l'épidémie sont
offerts mais fin de citation un
confinement en tout cas nouvelle formule
plus léger et qui a commencé sur un
couac
raillé pour sa complexité dès son entrée
en vigueur le dispositif d'attestation
de sortie de deux pages a finalement été
largement simplifié par le gouvernement
il ne sera plus nécessaire de motiver
ses déplacements jusqu'à 10 km un
justificatif de domicile suffira à
nouveau confinement qui n'est pas sans
conséquence sur la santé mentale
certains le mot allah ou plus bas guetté
par la dépression elle selon plusieurs
études publiées récemment une personne
sur sept a présenté ensemble tome un
syndrome dépressif depuis le printemps
dernier les femmes et les jeunes sont
les plus touchés chez les détails avec
maxime abers et clément hospital crise
sanitaire et économique confinement le
moral défoncé n'a jamais été aussi bas
13 5% des personnes âgées de 15 ans ou
plus parle de symptômes évocateurs d'un
état dépressif un bilan en nette
augmentation comparé à l'année 2019
plusieurs facteurs expliquent ces
pathologies l'isolément les conditions
de logement
le manque de contacts sociaux et la
dégradation de la situation financière
tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes
capacités pour lutter contre le blues du
coc vide
selon cette même enquête réalisée par la
direction de la recherche des études de
l'évaluation et des statistiques les 15
24 ans seraient les plus touchées plus
10% par rapport à 2010 9 un constat
partagé par l'université de bordeaux
l'établissement a mis en place une
formation dédiée à la détection de ces
troubles
dépression pensées suicidaires les
enseignants qui apprennent à repérer les
premiers signes de détresse
psychologique envers du confinement en
fait à a poussé beaucoup d'entre nous à
gérer des situations pour lesquelles
n'étaient pas vraiment préparé quand des
étudiants venaient vers nous en création
de détresse ou
ils disaient ouvertement que vous avez
des pensées suicidaires beaucoup d'entre
vous ne savez pas comment le gérer on
essaie quand même de leur assurer on
n'est pas des flics on n'est pas des
plus sereins de santé on est des
étudiants comme eux et peut-être que
nous aussi on vit quelque chose comme ça
ils ne savent pas donc c'est à partir de
là quand qu'on arrive à apprendre prend
là autres catégories à risque les femmes
là encore l'adresse observe une
augmentation + 3,3 pour cent
une des causes avancées par l'étude le
fait de se retrouver face à des
comportements violents agressifs et
dégradant de la part du conjoint ou du
partenaire pendant le confinement les
violences familiales ont grimpé près
d'une femme sur dix a porté plainte pour
violences en 2020 30% d'entre elles
l'ont fait pour la toute première fois
l'étude liste aussi 4 source de troubles
mentaux quatre problèmes qui dans ce
contexte de pandémie ont pris de
l'ampleur
le fait d'être confiné seul ou dans des
foyers surpeuplée aurait favorisé des
états dépressifs par exemple sur ces
questions de santé mentale
les médecins sont en première ligne
trois sur quatre affirment que les
consultations pour stress troubles
anxieux ou dépressifs sont plus élevés
qu'avant la pandémie pour 16% d'entre
ces pathologies aurait même doublé en un
an
des chiffres qui explique sans doute la
nouvelle stratégie du gouvernement
confiné sans enfermer une fatigue
psychique et un moral en berne
un psychologue à paris là où brahim
constate dans son cabinet à écouter ce
que je vois en consultation beaucoup une
fatigue chez voilà on ne voit pas le
bout c'est aujourd'hui qu'on entend
beaucoup lors du premier confinement il
y avait quelque chose de un peu ou
presque que voilà excellent amusant
c'était un peu de leurs deux balades et
grandes vacances
on voyait un peu le bourg on a vu le
bois un moment donné d'ailleurs mais là
il ya une fatigue c'est chic et fatale
on ne sait pas où on va on ne va pas
vraiment le bout et je pense qu'il faut
structurer ne pas oublier de structurer
ces journées structurer ses semelles il
ne pas manquer cela lors du premier
confinement tout le monde voilà ce fait
beaucoup de choses
mené des activités je pense qu'il faut
partager pas que très important de
retrouver une culture danse et d'enfler
journée dans deux semaines un toulouse 9
ans après les habitants on oublie pas un
rassemblement était organisé aujourd'hui
si on mémoire de ses quatre enfants
juifs assassinés par mohamed merah le 20
mars 2012
plus d'une centaine de personnes ont
défilé dans le centre ville pour
dénoncer les crimes antisémites à
toulouse et ailleurs
mobilisation à l'appel de partis de
gauche des associations antiracistes ou
culturelles une minute de silence a été
observée
les restrictions de passe par en
allemagne à cassel une ville du centre
du pays des heurts ont éclaté cet après
midi entre la police et des opposants
aux mesures contre locaux vides
plusieurs milliers de contestataires
s'était retrouvée sur une place du
centre ville
serrés les uns contre les autres souvent
son masque de protection
l'un des plus grands rassemblements de
ce type depuis le début de l'année en
allemagne à les forces de l'ordre ont
fait usage de gaz au poivre pour
repousser les manifestants
le pays est confronté lui aussi à une
troisième vague de l'épidémie malgré les
mesures prises pour freiner la
propagation du virus
hier l'allemagne a enregistré seize
mille nouveaux cas de contamination et
207 morts supplémentaires
respectez votre contrat avec l'europe
avant de commencer à livrer d'autres
pays
la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen menace
aujourd'hui astrazeneca de bloquer les
exportations de son bac sens si les
livraisons prévues dans lieux ne sont
pas effectués le groupe cdh au
britannique déjà sur la sellette après
une suspicion d'effets secondaires
graves mais astrazeneca qui pèse lourd
dans la stratégie vaccinale de l'europe
la vaccination a repris hier dont
plusieurs pays européens où certains
dirigeants vous allez le voir n'ont pas
hésité à donner de leur personne pour
redonner confiance dans le sérum
guingamp doucet
les retards de livraison des doses
d'astrazeneca pose question au sein de
l'union européenne
ce samedi bruxelles a mis la pression
sur le laboratoire britannique et
menacent de bloquer les exportations du
vaccin s'il venait pas servis en
priorité nous avons l'option d'interdire
toute exportation prévu c'est le message
que nous passons à astrazeneca respecter
votre contrat avec l'europe avant de
commencer à livrer d'autres pays toutes
les options sont sur la table
une sortie qui pourrait perturber la
vaste opération reconquête entamé en
cette fin de semaine vendredi le premier
ministre français jean castex a reçu une
première dose du vaccin d'astrazeneca
une injection pour faire taire les
critiques et redorer le blason du vaccin
anglo-suédois même volonté de rassurer
outre manche où boris johnson s'est
également fait vacciner j'avais une
infirmière merveilleuse qui s'appelait
lilly et elle m'a dit que j'allais avoir
un choc mais je n'ai littéralement rien
senti donc c'était très bien très rapide
vous savez ce que je vais dire je ne le
recommanderais jamais assez donc tout le
monde
lorsque vous allez recevoir votre
notification pour le vaccin allez-y et
faites-le s'il vous plaît c'est la
meilleure chose pour vous pour votre
famille et pour tout le monde
le premier ministre italien mario draghi
ainsi que la chancelière allemande
angela merkel ont également annoncé
qu'ils allaient se faire vacciner avec
le sérum d'astrazeneca
malgré le feu vert de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments jeudi la
prudence est de mise et les calendriers
de reprise de la vaccination diffèrent
selon les pays
en france la vaccination a repris ce
vendredi
mais le vaccin d'astrazeneca est
désormais limité aux personnes de plus
de 55 ans l'allemagne l'italie la
bulgarie ou encore la slovénie ont tablé
sur le même calendrier que la france
l'espagne le portugal ou encore les
pays-bas ont quant à eux choisi
d'attendre la semaine prochaine le
danemark la norvège et la suède ont de
leur côté décidé de prendre leur temps
avant de se prononcer sur l'utilisation
du vaccin d'astrazeneca
quant à la finlande elle a suspendu ce
vendredi le vaccin en raison d'une
suspicion au sujet de deux cas de
thrombose après injection d'une dose
d'astrazeneca
compte tenu du fait que l'agencé
européenne des médicaments a déclaré que
ce type de problème a été signalé par un
certain nombre de pays
l'autorité sanitaire finlandaise a
décidé en vertu du principe de
précaution de suspendre l'utilisation du
vaccin d'astrazeneca pour la prochaine
semaine
en fin de semaine dernière plusieurs
pays européens avaient pris la même
décision que la finlande la polémique
concernant les risques liés au vaccin a
eu pour conséquence directe la montée en
puissance du scepticisme en france selon
un sondage au doxa bakbone consulting
56% des personnes interrogées ne veulent
pas ou plus se faire vacciner avec le
sérum d'astrazeneca ce vendredi
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
porte en caractérisée comme je cite un
vaccin importante et à encourager les
différents pays à l'utiliser contre le
coc vite 19 comme il conclu la belle
blonde est agnostique le comité a conclu
que les données disponibles ne suggère
aucune augmentation générale des
pathologies de coagulation
après l'administration du vaccin
d'oxford astrazeneca et si le comité a
recommandé le vaccin d'astrazeneca
c'est parce que ses bienfaits
l'emportent sur les risques éventuels
et qu'il présente un potentiel énorme
pour prévenir des infections et des
décès dus aux copies de 19
quoi qu'il en soit la confiance envers
astrazeneca a sérieusement été écornée
par les récents événements et la
stratégie lancée pour retrouver
l'adhésion de la population s'annonce
ardue direction l'italie chevaux matteo
salvini comparaissaient ce samedi devant
la justice le procureur de palerme a
demandé sa mise en examen l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur est soupçonné de
séquestration de personne et d'abus de
pouvoir pour avoir interdit le
débarquement d'une centaine de migrants
secourues en mer par l'omg
oppenheim c'était en août 2019 retour
sur cette affaire avec media escaffit un
bateau humanitaire empêché de débarquer
sur les côtes italiennes
voilà la sphère au coeur du procès du
leader de la ligue qui a eu lieu ce
samedi le parquet de palerme en sicile a
annoncé vouloir traduire matteo salvini
en justice ce dernier est accusé d'abus
de pouvoir et de séquestration de
personne
des accusations pour lesquelles il
risque jusqu'à 15 ans de prison
l' affaire remonte à août 2019 plus de
80 migrants sont sauvés en mer par une
ong espagnole open arms alors que les
conditions de vie deviennent difficiles
à bord du navire
matteo salvini s'oppose fermement à
l'arrivée de ce dernier sur le sol
italien ministre de l'intérieur à
l'époque selvini a été auditionné une
première fois sur cette affaire en
janvier dernier il s'agissait ce samedi
de sa deuxième audition les services du
parquet de palerme réclame une
inculpation et un procès contre moi pour
enlèvement inquiète absolument pas je
suis fier d'avoir oeuvré à la protection
de mon pays dans le respect des lois en
réveillant l'europe finalement autorisé
par un procureur de 6 il a débarqué les
83 migrants parviennent à gagner la
petite île de lampedusa après 19 jours
passés à bord du bateau à l'origine de
cette opération
los andes pagnol se réjouit de la
décision du parquet de palerme violer
les droits de personnes vulnérables est
un crime dans n'importe quel pays
démocratique
qui respecte la constitution et les
conventions internationales
l'ancien ministre italien de l'intérieur
a déjà été mis en cause dans une affaire
similaire qui a eu lieu également durant
l'été 2010 9 salvini avait alors bloqué
le navire grégory this transportant 116
migrants en décembre dernier le parquet
sicilien de catane a demandé l'abandon
des poursuites à son encontre
avocat au barreau de milan et de paris
s'y repérer les nous explique la
procédure italienne particulièrement
technique il faudra en effet attendre
une troisième audience en avril pour
savoir si matteo salvini sera jugé ou
non dans cette affaire le juge de
l'audience le ligne va décider comment
il doit décider 1
il peut décider de confirmer le décret
dès la mois du rigueur mais si lui il
estime le juge des audiences
préliminaires et bien sûr ils estiment
qu'ils les éléments probants douanes un
qui a la charge des mossi servi nenê
sont pas suffisants pour pouvoir
soutenir intégrer des rats mois à ces
moments avec vous les mêmes disposer
d'une ultérieure face del'enquête c'est
à dire pour les côtés encore des
éléments beaumanoir ou attention quel
est le troisième scénario remercier ma
vie ou aux firmes le délai d'un mois
deuxième scénario il pourrait intégrer
et donc disposer à l'égal de dieu
ultérieure activités d'enquêté
il ya aussi un beau jeans et radio le
juge de l'audience préliminaire ils
peuvent statuer par intégrer le lot lieu
à poser des manifestations en espagne
pour demander la libération de pablo à
celle le rappeur catalans ont été
incarcérés en février dernier condamné à
de la prison ferme pour apologie du
terrorisme et injures contre la
monarchie espagnole on retrouve à
barcelone notre correspondantle et
skating là
bonsoir les skis vous êtes donc à
barcelone où se tenait l'un des
rassemblements les plus importants ce
soir ils étaient des centaines pour le
premier mois d'incarcération du rappeur
catalan arrêté le 7 février dernier
c'était symbolique pour eux de se
retrouver aujourd'hui la plateforme du
soutien pablo à celle avait tenu à
convoquer plusieurs rassemblements en
même temps dans différentes villes de
catalogne alors on le rappelle pablo un
seul a été condamné une première fois
pour apologie du terrorisme et un jour à
l'encontre de la couronne ça concerne en
tout 64 tweets publiés entre 2014 et
2016 est une chanson contre l'ancien roi
d'espagne juan carlos puis là sa peine a
été alourdie
juste après son arrestation il a été
condamné pour avoir menacé le témoin
témoin pendant un procès en 2017
et puis la semaine dernière l'audience
nationale a ajouté 16 mois de prison
supplémentaires pour ne pas avoir payé
trois amendes
le rappeur catalan avait déclaré depuis
le début qu'il ne les paierai pas et
depuis je riais ce que la mobilisation a
faibli examine les manifestations se
font moins régulière alors il faut
rappeler que suite à l'arrestation
mouvementée du rappeur catalans qui
s'était retranché dans une université de
catalogne des rassemblements s'était
tenue le jour même mais aussi les
semaines suivantes
à barcelone les dégâts dans l'espace
public avait dépassé le million d'euros
au total en catalogne 142 personnes ont
été arrêtées alors plus que de demander
la liberté de pablo à sel et de prôner
la liberté d'expression c'est devenu un
conglomérat de luttes sociales
car après un an de pandémie et de
restrictions l'arrestation de pablo à
celle a été l'étincelle qui a enflammé
les jeunes militants barcelonais c'est
une façon pour eux de montrer leur
hostilité face au gouvernement espagnol
mais aussi de pointer du doigt la
précarité car en espagne le chômage bat
des records nous devrons le joint les
retraites font également partie des
revendications
et même si les revendications sont
nombreuses la mobilisation est en baisse
le soutien politique a également faibli
en main en février les réactions étaient
nombreuses mais ce mois de mars elles se
sont faites plus rares
merci beaucoup de nice l'acide leslie
singh là en direct de barcelone
la contestation ne faiblit pas en
birmanie malgré la répression
nouvelle manifestation ce samedi elles
sont presque quotidiennes depuis le coup
d'état militaire qui a renversé l'ex
dirigeante en scène sushil 1er février
les protestataires se disent prêts à se
battre jusqu'au bout contre la junte en
un mois et demi que près de 240 civils
ont été tués des centaines de personnes
sont également portées disparues à
rangoon la capitale économique à les
habitants fuient leur ville
le récit de fedex ul des sacs de sable
et des tables comme barricades
les manifestants ne fléchissent pas face
aux balles de l'armée en birmanie les
rassemblements continuent plus de 240
civils sont déjà morts depuis le coup
d'état du 1er février et plusieurs
grévistes et journalistes sont portés
disparus dans la capitale économique
rangoon
les scènes de départs massifs se
multiplient vers les régions d'origine
ou les pays frontaliers
d'autres mobilisations prennent
également forme dans les usines textiles
comme dans les banques les grèves se
multiplient
un mouvement de désobéissance civile
ayant un seul but et tout fait
l'économie pour faire reculer le pouvoir
militaire tant que leader des
travailleurs et en tant que citoyenne
ordinaire de la birmanie je ne peux plus
vivre sous la dictature militaire
je ne peux pas non plus laisser notre
nouvelle génération la subir
pour cette raison je combattrai la
dictature militaire de toutes mes forces
mentalement et physiquement je
continuerai à me battre jusqu'à ce que
nous ferez loison démocratie et jusqu'à
mon dernier souffle
même si je ne peux pas dire ce qui se
passera dans le faisant fi de la cam a
dans le même temps les pressions
internationales se multiplient dans la
région le président indonésien a
condamné les violences et appelé ses
homologues du sud est asiatique a
organisé un sommet sur la crise
l'indonésie demande instamment que l'
usage de la violence en birmanie cessent
immédiatement afin qu'il n'y ait plus de
victimes
l'indonésie demande également instamment
qu'un dialogue en vue de la
réconciliation soient menés
immédiatement afin de rétablir la
démocratie la paix et la stabilité en
birmanie
je m'entretiendrai immédiatement avec le
sultanat de brunei qui préside
actuellement la séan afin qu'une réunion
de haut niveau puisse être organisée
pour discuter de la crise en birmanie
tsonga la can aux etats unis la chambre
des représentants a voté cette nuit une
résolution exigeant des dirigeants
birmans la libération de tous les
opposants emprisonnés en europe
bruxelles se prépare également à prendre
des mesures coercitives
selon des sources diplomatiques l'union
européenne devrait sanctionner lundi 11
officiers de l'armée birmane impliqués
dans la répression
il n'y aura pas de spectateurs venus de
l'étranger aux jo de tokyo une triste
première dans l'histoire de l'olympisme
moderne et une nouvelle qui ne réjouit
pas les athlètes mais qui s'avère
nécessaire selon les organisateurs pour
assurer que l'événement elle se déroule
dans de bonnes conditions sanitaires en
pleine pandémie
la présidente du comité d'organisation
expliqué le timing de cette décision à
quatre mois des premières épreuves et
tokyo nîmes 0 ni 0 takano kanka qu'en ce
qui concerne la présence des supporters
aux jeux de tokyo
lorsque nous avons envisagé les
réservations d'hébergements et de vol
nous avons pensé qu'il valait mieux
prendre une décision le plus tôt
possible
il y avait également des demandes au
niveau national pour prendre une
décision au plus vite
nous avons donc décidé à ce moment là de
prendre une décision kate est ce le
conte en amenant des limaces et c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi prochain point sur l'actu dans une
trentaine de minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on s'en
doutait qu il est clair que tout le
monde attend ça est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre